so I'm taking a quote that you have here
I met my best when I'm telling extremely
personal stories mmm
would you say you're an open book you're
okay with people knowing things about
you absolutely yeah I I like to in fact
I try to challenge myself to be even
more open I don't feel like I'm as open
as I need to be and what I mean by that
is like I I've always had like sort of
an outsider perspective growing up and
I've always felt like I have a reservoir
of almost like pain and truth from which
to draw from and I've noticed that like
whenever I'm telling stories that aren't
very personal there's like something
kind of missing about it there's like
there's like it's almost like an athlete
in the fourth quarter who doesn't have
their legs under them you know what I
mean to shoot a jump shot but I noticed
that when I when I really lean into my
truth and I lean into the things that
mean a lot to me and lean into the
things that have value and things I can
talk about it at length and just kind of
keep keep going on and seem to never
really run out of energy those are my
best stories that did I tell and I also
think there's something to be sad about
because a professor of mine when I was
at school
it's a Vincent Robert said this to me he
said why do we tell stories and he asked
that one day and everybody in class was
like raising their hands saying all
these different things and we were all
wrong and he said no no we tell stories
to heal that's why we tell stories and I
had a moment where I
I almost couldn't breathe because I
realized he was totally right at least
for me I realized that's why I tell
stories because there's something about
opening up an old wound trying to heal
it in a way where other people can see
it that absolutely heals them too at
least that's what I've experienced so
like in in in my film my film is all
about these two strangers who are
actually brothers who learned
become brothers that's what the whole
movies about and it's based on like a
true story of my actual extremely broken
relationship with my older brother and
you know we both grew up like total
opposites like he I was very much a
private-school try to make straight A's
kind of kid and and my other brother
like basically hung out in the streets
and you know had a very vibrant very
successful life in crime and I just
didn't understand it I didn't get it and
it hurt me for so so so many years and I
knew that like oh man if I tell a story
about that and I can like I can make fun
of myself make fun of all the things
that that are I'll basically make light
of all the things that cause me pain I
know for a fact there's gonna be other
people out there that are experiencing
something similar that can relate to it
because a lot of times when you're super
specific about the things that that
caused you pain you can achieve almost
like a universal sense of connection
with other people because other people
can see themselves in very specific
stories and I knew that and that was
something I learned throughout school
and so like I I've noticed that every
single time I do that every single time
I'm honest and I'm open
I usually connect with way more people
than if I tried to be someone else or
tried to tell someone else's story that
didn't fit me I didn't I didn't have
like a I always have to find like an
emotional end that moves me deeply to my
core
something I can speak about at length
and when that happens whenever I know
sort of thematically why I'm telling the
story then I can I feel like I could
make a 10 hour movie about it you know
but yeah so I always try to tell stories
are extremely personal and try to be as
open as possible about it I'm trying to
be even more open about
the just the process of what it takes to
put a movie together and the pain that
goes with that - yeah see people respect
that honesty cuz a lot of us don't show
different things we just want to put oh
no everything's great I got this kind of
you know that's become this new term and
I feel like we've become a society of
like I got this I'm good and I'm not you
know yeah and and the reality is like
human beings we are created for
community like we're not really created
I know our society is very individual
you know we celebrate the individual
like the the accomplishments of the
individual like I did this I'm awesome
you know and you know there's there's
something to that about like living up
to your potential ISM
as a person as a as a creator or
whatever it is that you're doing but I
think when we deny the fact that we need
to connect with other people we do
ourselves and everyone around us a
disservice because something magical
happens when when people open up to each
other and you sort of take a risk and
you wanted to trust another person
something kind of beautiful happens in
that and I think in today's day and age
like it's very easy to like open up
Instagram and look around it'd be like
man everybody's crushing it but me
and in the reality like we're all super
broken people like all of us are broken
there's not one person on this planet
that's not broken and when you can sort
of embrace that you embrace a part of
your humanity and I feel like if you
deny that suddenly you're you're trying
you're running away from the from
basically your own fingerprints the
thing that the things that make you
uniquely you and I think the more you
embrace your faults your weaknesses and
and even your strengths because
sometimes there can be shame involved in
embracing your own strengths just
embracing who you are the the good and
the bad only makes you a more valuable
contributing member of society how does
it feel to come here
and and want to tell stories you came
from
where it was very embracing and a warm
family that welcomes you but do you feel
a sense of of like freedom well now I
can tell other new stories or is it
scarier or how is that because it seems
like maybe people really knew you back
home and and now not saying that people
don't know you but it's there's so many
people here yeah that it's different so
how is that is that freeing is that
scary is it kind of both or I think it's
a bit of both I think the only thing
that I think this entire process has has
taught me is that to not have shame in
telling stories that excite you of it
might because there there are some
stories I know for a fact that my mother
would hate it if I told that story what
if like oh if I put that scene in a
movie my mom's gonna kill me
yeah but like I I've now to the point
where like yes I do know that there are
a lot of stories and me that I I'm
confident we'll probably make someone
mad or you know who perhaps like my
other films and things like that but the
reality is that like we're all
constantly evolving as people and you
know just because something makes
someone uncomfortable doesn't mean
there's not truth in it
because a lot of times I mean I mean we
just right now in our society like we
all we're all running from the truth
I've got a lot of things because it
makes us uncomfortable and I think like
as long as I can find and tell stories
that I feel are authentic to me where I
can lean into truth and embrace it lean
and pain and embrace it then I'm going
to as much as possible aggressively
pursue those types of stories and I'm I
think one thing about perhaps like ever
since ever since I finished my my
feature I think I've really begun to
realize like you know just how much
effort it takes to make a film and how
much how much craft and and work and
sweat and
all these different things it takes to
craft a story to where someone else can
enjoy it and and get what it is you're
trying to do that now like for instance
my films moving forward like I'm gonna
make them even more when try my best to
make them even more honest and even more
embrace like the parts of me that are in
the movie more because with as much
effort as you put into these things like
yeah might as well make them as potent
and as sharp and as resonant emotionally
as possible
you